non-minimalists
yeah man well well i think i think yeah
it's probably best to start by by
talking about what is what is an
addiction and we'll
also differentiate it from a few things
so okay
um according to the national institute
of health addiction
is the condition of being addicted to a
particular substance
thing or activity despite harmful
consequences and it is
often characterized by an inability to
stop i had um some smart out lucky
person on twitter yesterday say
how can you help me stop my addiction to
oxygen i can't stop and
okay that's not what an addiction is
because oxygen itself
has very beneficial properties to it
there's not
an alternative yeah it's interesting
because like before i even
like before we decided to do this
podcast
i would have agreed with him i would
have been like oh yeah i mean you have
to have oxygen or you die
right there are a lot of things we have
to have or or we benefit from yeah
i benefit from having a bed i'm not
addicted to having
the bed because there are no harmful
consequences of having the bed
right there's a piece of lint right here
on your microphone oh we have to remove
is that it yeah i'm so so did i get it i
have ocd you totally got it
and um so let's talk real quick about
the difference between
addiction and obsession there's a lot of
overlap like if you have a venn diagram
of addiction and obsession there's going
to be this huge sort of
overlap so okay i have this definition
here i
broke my computer out so that we could
talk about it this is from cliffside
malibu which i believe is a
addiction treatment center and the
article here which put a link to in the
show notes it's called what's the
difference between addiction
and obsession i'm just going to read the
first two paragraphs
when the average person thinks about
addiction most people think about drugs
alcohol
tobacco and maybe shopping or gambling
when a person is
addicted to drugs or alcohol they are
chemically dependent on the drug
and you could say the same thing about
well caffeine is a drug obviously
yeah it's weird we say drugs and alcohol
but alcohol is just a drug we could
we can say drugs well yeah because it's
a drugs tobacco
and alcohol and those are all tobacco
and alcohol or drugs
right and and those are all addictive
drugs there are some drugs however that
are not
addictive um uh lsd is a non or
psilocybin
is a non-addictive drug it does not have
the same addictive properties now you
can become
psychologically addicted to virtually
anything
yeah i could be uh addicted to
styrofoam or to very clean microphones
yes well that's more about obsession
which we'll dive into here
uh in a second right people who suffer
from addiction
many times also have other co-occurring
disorders
such as obsessive-compulsive disorder
there's a strong correlation between
addiction and obsessions and obsession
is a ritualistic routine that becomes
part
of your normal life medically speaking
it is a persistent occupation of a
feeling or idea
which can be accompanied by anxiety and
i think it's one of the reasons i
i'm often my levels of anxiety tend to
be higher than yours
um it has a lot to do we both have a
addictive personalities which we're
going to touch on in this episode for
sure
they manifest differently mine manifests
often through
through obsession which is this
ritualistic routine or ritualistic
thinking
obsessions can include excessive hand
washing or repetitive counting i
i don't have obsession obsessive hand
washing although
um i know yesterday we were on a flight
we were flying back from chicago and
that guy who was sitting next to me
totally like it was coughing and stuff
and i'm like
all right i'm going to ask him if he'll
switch seats with you and
we ended up working out but like i
definitely went into the bathroom and
washed my hands but that that to me
was just reasonable i mean yeah it's
preventative
right i mean dude i get on an airplane
and i got those little sanitizing wipes
right like i wipe everything down
because
you know i just i read this article a
year or so ago where they were talking
about how
it was like confessions of a flight
attendant or something and one of the
confessions was
those trays that come down and
everything the screens those
never get cleaned and it's amazing
sometimes how you take one of those
wipes and you wipe everything down and
it's like
black almost yeah it's crazy so so yeah
it's being preventative all right yeah
so there's a difference between being
preventative and and being excessively
preventative and that's when obsession
comes the counting thing that it
mentions here
um that's definitely something i have
and i don't always notice
um like i can tell you right now there
are 44 steps between my car
the the stairs within the in the parking
garage and the bottom floor
yeah like it's just something that that
i don't realize i'm doing it i'm just
counting as i go
one two three four and and i find myself
counting different things
from time to time unintentionally an
addiction is slightly different
rather than a focus on ritual an
addiction
is about a mental escape from reality
obsessive and addictive behavior
behavior can be co-mingled
rather easily by recognizing what an abs
what is obsessive and what is addictive
however
you can go back to each individual route
and address the underlying problem
the rest of this article talks about
therapy can be very beneficial there are
different types of therapy like cbt
therapy
cognitive behavioral therapy
to address obsessive-compulsive disorder
and also to address
addictions now we're going to talk about
addictions more broadly today let me
hand my computer over here to jordan no
more
and um let's see uh i think with
with the questions we're going to deal
with today we'll talk about
alcohol and substance abuse but we'll
also talk about the broader
addictions before we get into that
though like i think one of the reasons
that minimalism was appealing to both of
us is it was helping us in a way
curb our addictions or really get the
superfluous things out of the way
or maybe it's maybe it's a matter of
like getting rid of the addictions
and bringing in obsessions maybe uh well
there are different types of obsessions
right healthy
obsessions like i get obsessed with
writing and and
and for me i think love is one half
passion one half half um obsession
but it has to be the sort of healthy
obsession and that equation works when
you flip it around as well passion is
one half love
one half healthy obsession so to say
healthy obsession it seems a bit
redundant
because obsession by definition is
something that is
uh healthy it's helpful at least not
necessarily it's ritualistic in a way so
so
uh obsession itself is
is bipartisan in this case right it
it can be healthy just like it's like
saying food
there's some terrible food out there
that's going to kill us and give us butt
cancer
yeah um there are other foods that are
going to nourish our bodies
make us energetic make us feel like our
best selves
and prevent butt cancer and perfect butt
cancer but see
but see when i get but when an object
when an obsession turns unhealthy
that's when it becomes an addiction it
usually that is the case yeah because
um an obsession be turns ritualistic
or or just become we become dependent on
alcoholism
which i've had a lot of experience with
uh personally
not i'm not an alcoholic well actually i
probably am an alcoholic i've never had
a drink in my life
because both of my parents were
alcoholics and i saw the
the extreme and they were extreme
alcoholics and not even functioning
alcoholics and it ruined
their lives and and i saw that happen
and
and for me i saw the that ritual
turned in it devolved into it wasn't
even a ritual
anymore it was just an everyday all
waking hours occurrence yeah until
they were both dead well let's talk
about like writing so
you're obsessed with writing yeah but
let's say that you were writing
this morning and you were getting so
obsessed with it
that you were like you know what i'm not
gonna leave this room
until this is done right and you called
jordan
and shawn and i and you're like sorry
guys cancel on the podcast cancel
everything today i've got to finish what
i'm writing
right and then like you don't leave your
room for a week until you
finally so is that
does is at that point is it an addiction
i think so yeah
i i think because if we go back to that
initial
definition from the nih addiction is the
condition of being addicted to a
particular substance thing or activity
right it would be an activity in this
case
despite harmful consequences right and
so when you start neglecting everything
else now now
for us we were we were actually
neglecting
the most important things in our lives
the our health our relationships our
creativity
so i was neglecting writing for a long
time now my drug of choice was
consumerism
also sort of status and achievement and
success uh
accolades it's a weird thing to like
want
you know trophies or whatever whatever
the equivalent of trophies are in our
consumer culture
the trophies are often the trinkets or
the objects that we're able to acquire
with the money which is the barometer of
of success often in our culture yeah um
and now there's this new barometer as
well and in the world of social media
it's a
it's social media clout that becomes
something that we become addicted to
it's like like oh wow and the weird
thing is you know you and i will
sometimes joke with each other about
this like
oh now i have now we have you know 300
followers on x platform
i guess i'm allowed to be happy now like
this is the key to happiness of course
it's
not though because then you see the
person with half a million
or a million or 10 million or 50 million
followers
and you feel inadequate so we get
addicted to
the comparison we get addicted to the
success yeah so the perceived
success so could social media be a
healthy obsession
yes i i think so because it's a vehicle
right
and i think i think a lot of the times
you and i we have a very deliberate way
of how we use social media in fact we
hired jessica
so that she could help us be deliberate
with how we are
using social media we use it as a
platform to do two things one is
to broadcast a message that we find will
add to the greater good so
we're trying to add value to other
people's lives we want to add to the
greater good
but also we want to interact with people
as well and so we use social media
to interact in a positive way not to not
to interact with the trolls or
or to fuel and to feed the trolls fuel
the fire
of outrage uh because that that can be
the unhealthy side of it we can get
addicted to the
oh well i'm gonna get you back or
whatever there's some people who do it
really well i think crystalia he has a
really fun time
um feeding the trolls and then
subsequently killing them
killing the trolls you know uh with his
with his words but he's
he that's his art form in a way um
and and so yes it can be it can be
addictive or it could be a healthy
obsession now for you and i you know for
me consumerism
was the the drug of choice for my my
my parents their drug of choice was was
alcohol yeah my drug of choice was drugs
my drug of choice was drugs of choice
yes
and and those became not
just physically addictive because they
certainly were i remember you going
through withdrawals
but also psychologically addictively i
need this in order to get through the
day or to get through this
relationship get through this job get
through this interaction get through
this
day of meetings and it became this sort
of psychological addiction as well
yeah and and that's the the dangerous
side of
of substances that are addictive is
they're both chemically addictive yeah
and psychologically addictive yeah
that's dangerous
you